you or product doesn't solve a problem
how do you put you ah okay great
question
so it's very easy to pitch people a
product that removes pain it's like hey
if you take this pill then your back
pain goes away what you're selling is
hey you take this pill and you might
avoid being sick this is why we say pain
killers versus vitamins like when people
are in pain they're like I need a
painkiller right now give me a
painkiller or give me three shots of
tequila
I need something to turn off the pain
that's like that acute like I need it
right now vitamins you got to convince
people listen the study said this you're
getting more vitamin C you need vitamin
B for this reason you know so when
you're pitching it I think you know
having a prototype having some early
beta users who have used the product and
who talked about how much they love it
and then there are frameworks for this
what is called Net Promoter Score
there's another one where you ask people
if this product went away would you be
devastated would you be really
disappointed somewhat disappointed or
not disappointed at all right and Raul
from superhuman recently wrote a blog
post about this so there are ways when
the products in market to try to get to
this very issue which is hey it's not
solving exactly a problem for them like
Netflix I mean you could say Netflix
solves the problem of what am I gonna
watch tonight but really you know video
games and Netflix and things that
entertain us and delight us they're
harder to quantify in that way and so
when pitching them I think early user
reviews and the people who use it
telling their story so if this was if
this was an app like say calm calm for
meditation if you had somebody who said
my daughter was having a hard time going
to bed and it was drama every night
until we got sleep stories and now I let
her pick a sleep story and there's no
fighting when she goes to bed and she's
asleep you know nine out of ten times
within 20 minutes
this has been a game-changer for our
family which is true in my family
actually London right and so that
testimonial a testimonial can in
somebody else selling your product your
customer selling your product is better
than you trying to sell your product
does that make sense yes good people
don't believe you you're you're an
interested party you made it right
you're like oh my yeah my meditation my
sleep app app you know solves all the
problems in the world so you prove it
well okay here's a customer and here by
the way here's five customers and that's
why ratings you know in a way when we
see the ratings in on Amazon or Yelp you
know those ratings and Yelp help us make
sense of the world right and people like
giving their feedback so I would ask
your customers or your early users can
you write me you know send them a survey
and say hey can you rate the product on
these four different categories with
numbers and then the last thing say as a
bonus and we'll give you a $5 gift card
from Amazon for this please write a yelp
like three or four sentence review of
the product what it means to you how you
use it and what delights you about it
and if you asked them in that way hey
write a yelp like review our product
they'll give you a Yelp like a review
right and they'll get the $5 gift card
and then you pull all those now we do
this for founder University every time
with Emmy award-winning producer Jackie
at the end we say hey write a yelp like
review then we take all those answers
and we give it to the marketing team and
they make ads out of it right okay how
brilliant is that right so you're
getting feedback from your customers and
your customers in our case founders and
entrepreneurs they understand our
product and can discuss it better than
us
seemed and so you might seen we've been
doing some marketing tests for this week
in startups cuz it's going so well we
want more people to find out about so
we'd actually been experimenting with
spending you know you know thousands of
dollars a month on some ads and one of
the ads we've been running is just here
are the reviews from iTunes and when we
run the review samaritans somebody said
like this is like getting 10 MBA
Wow I mean I couldn't come up with that
like oh you're watching this week's like
getting ten MBAs you know what it is ten
years every year it's an MBA it clearly
is like getting ten MBAs I love it but I
wouldn't have come up with it so that's
what I would wish for you okay what is
the product you know it's a like a
similar - it's a cross between an arcade
game a video game and a table game so
it's interactive
ping-pong table and interactive ping
pong table oh my lord
I love playing ping pong and I love the
idea
does it keep score does it light up
where the ball hit what does it do it
actually goes out where the ball hits so
the object of the game is to there's
squares lit up when you think there's
there's lots of different most basic
mode is that you are trying to knock out
all of your opponent's ways oh my god
they made Tetris ping pong yes or break
out it's more break out ping pong Breger
yeah more like break up oh my lord you
are a genius up in Syracuse or Oneonta
or wherever the hell you are what is
this call this product this is a genius
idea sir got cool tap yep the AP GL o
tap glow we're gonna have to work on the
name sir but this is a great effort and
you would make an inventor up in 15 feet
of snow up in Syracuse or Oneonta
Buffalo somewhere yeah yeah you like
some electrical engineer or something
are just some whacked-out guy who just
comes up with sick awesome ideas that
comes up about some ideas I guess how
many bong rips did you do before having
this idea this is a killer idea Burning
Man
yes I was tech support on a large car
and oh really
we don't spelling boys okay I don't know
forest house but you know I go to
Burning Man every other year or so
listen dude I don't know what you were
tripping on
but it all means Jackie whatever he has
give it to all the founder University
attendees next time we're gonna spike
the punch room come on better ideas this
is a great idea I'm dead serious do you
have you built the prototype yet oh yeah
I got a fully working prototype same
connection pretty much this week how
much is gonna go for retail 11 K 11 K
whoa and so that means you've got a 50%
margin on it or something yep
fantastic do you know do you know two
bit circus no okay look up two bit
circus
they are building new arcade games and
carnival type games they have a location
in Los Angeles in downtown LA Brent
Brent Bushnell who is the son of the
founder of Atari Nolan Bushnell is built
this new style arcade he would buy this
from you and if he does another ten
locations or something is he buy ten of
them from your him they might get pop
you buy two of them and then there's a
spin spin is a ping pong you know spin
you should oh you did did are they did
you give them an exclusive time they'll
be the exclusive in their city if they
buy four units of each you know I did
they got an awesome response and they
have not said anything well they went
dark reached out yeah reached out four
five times oh my lord
I want one of these tables it's a great
idea this is exactly the type of thing
that will appeal to Generation X Atari
2600 kids like myself the millennial
generation that grew up on you know Call
of Duty and you know started to get into
mobile gaming and now this new overwatch
you know minecraft generation you know
who grew up on casual games it's you
you're literally gonna be a multi
generally generational win and you can
do this with pool and you could do this
with shuffle board as well and what's
great about it is you can come up with
all different variations of games like I
would love to play this where you the
name of the
is every volley here's my version every
volley doubles the number the value of
the game right so I hit it it's one you
hit it it's two I hit it back to its
four
you hit it it's a then it's sixteen you
get the idea so now we're at 64 we've
gone back and forth whatever times yep
and it lights up a small ping-pong sized
target whoever hits the target first
gets the points if you miss that if you
screw up the volley in other words if
you break the volley then you lose that
'value so as it goes up it's like a game
of chicken you understand the stakes are
getting higher and higher and higher and
if you hit it you win so you can try to
target it but if you don't volley it and
you're on the twelve volley and this is
worth whatever 128 or 256 whatever it is
512 boom now you're gonna get Oh God
you are a genius I love this keep going
the lesson here is go to Burning Man
kids work on our cars come out with
creative ideas the thing is gonna be a
juggernaut you got a patent the [ __ ] out
of this send me an email you got my
email Jason Calacanis calm I want to see
this I mean want to buy one of these off
you have cost you may have to do it I
mean I don't need to get this that cost
from you I never asked for a freebie but
I think asking a cost after how
inspiring I've been to you would be yeah
you wouldn't take that the wrong way
would you no I wouldn't okay there we go
see that I feel Jacob all right thanks
for calling it